there is no sign whatsoever that joe  biden is running for re-election in  2024. kamala harris recently had to walk  back a statement she made kamala harris  during an interview said joe biden is  running  and i will be his running mate and the  next day she had to back it up and say  well actually uh joe biden intends to  run and when you keep hearing intends to  run  and they go beyond it and say he's  running and then they've got to back it  up and say that what i meant was he  intends to run not that he is running  it points to me that there is no way joe  biden is running for re-election so  let's look at a couple of clips here's  the first one this was an interview that  vice president kamala harris gave to cnn  and she sounded very definitive early  last week take a look joe biden is  running for re-election and i will be  his ticket mate wow  full stop pull stop right sounding  incredibly confident and yet  then she had to back it up